with a week and a half to go before the
presidential election which the Taliban
has threatened to disrupt the group
quickly claimed responsibility for both
attacks the first happened at a
re-election campaign rally for President
Ashraf Ghani in periban province the
Taliban says it's suicide bomber was
targeting Special Forces soldiers but as
with previous attacks most of those
killed and injured were civilians
suddenly a man on a motorbike arrived in
a huge explosion happened a lot of
people who are martyred and wounded the
attack will be a major concern for all
the presidential candidates as they
campaign across Afghanistan in the
coming days even more worrying for the
authorities here in Kabul was the second
attack happening in what should be one
of the most secure areas of the capital
the Taliban bomber managed to evade
tight security surrounding the
diplomatic area of the capital
detonating explosives at an office of
the Ministry of Defence I heard an
explosion and then dust started rising
from the site of the attack then there
was gunfire I escaped body parts were
spread everywhere it was confirmed the
gunfire was actually warning shots from
security forces trying to clear the area
because they feared a secondary attack
as the countdown to election day
continues the wider fear for the Afghan
government is keeping the security
situation stable enough to allow voting
to begin Rob McBride al Jazeera Kabul